we were in kharkiv for a week before the
war began now we have been back to the
city to see how those remaining are
struggling to survive under the barrage
we were taken to the northern suburb of
saltivca the worst hit area pounded by
russian forces across a no man's land
only a few miles to the north the number
of civilian deaths and injuries in that
area continues to rise this
is my report
the first thing you notice driving into
hakeev is that what little traffic there
is here is going the other way
this is a city largely emptied of life
deserted streets
destroyed buildings
and the ever-present sound of war
many of the targets like this one are
civilian we've come back to see how this
city is managing to survive
we go to meet roman and his group of
volunteers who are about to take
supplies into the worst hit area of this
city
we have decided to go with them there is
some shelling it's it's not it's safe to
go now no it's not safe but we must do
it
it is a drive through a suburban
wasteland
of shelled apartment blocks
shocked survivors surveying their
wrecked lives
and destruction
everywhere destruction
it is no place at all for anyone to live
but a few still do
and when help arrives they are overcome
thank you she tells the volunteers you
are very brave to come here
ludmila
is 74.
she tells us she has lived in saltifica
for half her life and for the last seven
weeks without electricity or running
water
somehow she survives below ground in the
darkness and the dam
what food she has is almost gone
what bed she has well it's this
and what candles she has are running out
a few floors above what is left of the
burnt out apartments
the rocket attacks and the shelling from
nearby russian forces are unrelenting
and there is no sign of it stopping soon
so we've heard
three
explosions near here shelling near here
in 10 minutes
15 minutes you know it's not too much
it's not so much for this place this
morning
it's only morning it's only they wake up
and do something it doesn't stop never
stop no
what a way we live how do they live i
don't know
[Music]
as if to prove his point on the very
same day
in a different part of soltifica another
attack caught by another camera crew
what brutality is this
it is random it is remorseless and it
begs a very simple question
why
you wanna
all i want is a peaceful sky says
ludmila
a peaceful sky and fresh bread
everywhere we went here they would
emerge from their darkness solitary pale
and looking for whatever roman has to
offer those who remain here
[Laughter]
a 94 year old neighbor they haven't seen
for some time finally emerges from her
home
is the war over she asked
and then an extraordinary moment
ludmilla offers her the food i don't
need it says her neighbor but she gives
it to her anyway
[Applause]
just think about that you're given food
to help you survive and you choose to
give that food
to somebody else
it is their home they told me and
they're not moving
this is where we live they say and this
is where we'll die